in general the way you make things cool
again is when high status people adopt
them so I guess if you wanted to make
marriage cool again
you'd have rich men and hot women
adopting it
as simple as that okay
hello and welcome to martial matters of
me Winston Marshall at spectator today
I'm joined by feminist theorist
columnist at unheard author of the book
the case against the sexual Revolution a
new Guide to Sex in the 21st century and
host of the maiden mother matriarch
podcast Louise Perry hello thank you so
much for joining me you're very welcome
thank you having me so I want to jump in
if I can before getting into your book
and and other such things with what I
think is
a motherhood crisis
and perhaps it's something that I'm over
worried about but the office of national
statistics suggests that I might not be
entirely wrong to be worried about it
but just they've reported this year that
now half of women
are childless at 30 which is for the
first time ever this is in Britain
that 18 of women aged 45 were childless
by 2020. and that mothers have on
average 1.92 children now which is lower
than the
2.08 that their mother's generation had
now I think you answer some of the some
of these issues for why this is the case
in your book which I'd like to get into
but I was speaking to this morning to
someone and I sort of assumed that this
was a bad thing and his reaction was
like well that's good we need fewer
people
and
um we need to have managed Decline and
so
what might be a very simple question is
is why is that bad do we need mothers
and do mothers do women need to have
children
yes you don't have to look far to find
people he'll say that that's a great
thing
um and he will see this
gradual decline in childbearing
um
which by the way goes back a
surprisingly long way
the decline in birth rates
associated with the Industrial
Revolution
um and also there's a decline in
mortality particularly infant mortality
described as the um described by by
demographers as the as the first
demographic transition
that's when basically every country
almost every country in the world now
has undergone the first demographic
transition fruition was the first
country to do so because we were the
first country to have an industrial
revolution and that's when you see uh
birth rates dropping from you know
seven
children per woman or something
extraordinarily high like that to just
above replacement and then you also have
low mortality and whatever that's so so
even before the pill comes on the
picture women are having
for your children but it's in the 1960s
when the pill arrives that you see this
very very sharp dip infertility and
again not just here right this is I I
think I'm I'm trying to recall
statistics exactly only three percent of
the world's population now live in a
country where birth rates are not
declining
so declining birth rates are the norm
and they started declining as I said
first in Britain but it's basically
happened everywhere it seems to just be
an inevitable consequence of
modernity mm-hmm the people people
have fewer children and there are a
whole bunch of reasons associated with
this
um the one that you'll hear most
commonly
shrimp
um
London Millennials is that it's
considered with house prices
and that here it is a factor it is that
has become more expensive particularly
in big Urban centers like London New
York San Francisco Tokyo wherever to
own property and raise children and and
there are all sorts of costs associated
with children that have become greater
and greater as time has gone by so that
is true that's not the only Factor
though because if that were the only
Factor then you wouldn't be seeing this
extraordinarily Global phenomenon of
falling fertility absolutely everywhere
regardless of house prices
um
it does seem to be just something about
modernity
mm-hmm
discourages family formation well
there's a few things from all angles
right so it's not just the economic
which I do happen to agree with that
that we think we want to do things in a
certain order and house prices are
ridiculous that still doesn't quite
answer the question
is it
do we need children is it bad is it bad
yeah like is that not you know in an age
where we're pummeled every day and being
told there's a climate apocalypse coming
yeah when the people are a problem
is it not a good thing that there there
are there are fewer people
so I think that
um
crushing birth rates is not going to
solve
the climate crisis
for a few reasons one is that it takes
too long right if the problem is that we
currently have close to 8 billion people
who are living in such a way that you
deplete natural resources as time goes
by which I think is true
um
having you know 1.5 replacement rate or
something like that below below the 2.1
necessary for replacement
is not going to
you know if Extinction rebellion and Co
a right that we're talking about
apocalypse within a century that's not
quick enough right to actually reduce
the burden on the planet so
that kind of gentle decline in
population is nowhere near enough to
avert catastrophe if that's the only
tool that you're employing so there's
that
um the other thing is that
birth rates are not declining evenly
this is something that people
don't always
bear in mind right in thinking about
this
so one example that um a very bad
actually from her this week is North and
South Korea so North Korea have just
below replacement level
birth rates which means that their
population is likely to dwindle a little
bit but not very much in the next half
century
whereas South Korea boasts the lowest
birth rates in the world not 0.78 I
think it is now whereas you need 2.1 to
for replacement which means that at the
moment
South Korea has twice as many people as
North Korea but in by 2 2100 so how do
you say it 2100 whatever yeah
that will have reversed so North Korea
will have twice as many people as South
Korea and they're a very very obvious
geopolitical consequences to that in
that it's predicted that in maybe 10 20
years South Korea will no longer be able
to repel a land Invasion from North
Korea because they won't have a big
enough military so that's the sort of
thing that we're thinking about you know
I think what the the fantasy of some
environmentalists
is that things will basically remain
exactly the same geopolitically
Etc but people will just have slightly
fewer children and eventually everything
will just kind of gradually shrink no
what happens is that some cultures are
more resistant to whatever it is about
modernity that causes fertility to climb
than our others and what we should
expect to happen as time goes by is that
those modernity resistant cultures are
going to become more dominant
and super modern secular Urban Etc
cultures like South Korean are going to
decline which is bad news if you
if your allegiances as most
environmentalists are if your
allegiances are with that kind of
super modern secular Urban culture
which is on which is on its way out
which is committing suicide effectively
because people do tend to obviously
there is some um
there are exceptions but people in
general do tend to adopt the
um religiosity and politics of their
parents because these things are partly
heritable religiosity is a moderately
heritable traits
um and one of the best predictors at the
moment for fertilities how religious you
are
worldwide that's true religious people
just have lots more kids
this also applies I think to
something like your interest in
environmentalism
you know if you're if you have this sort
of personality the sort of uh
um intelligence and temperament or
whatever that disposes you towards being
a climate activist
there's a fairly good chance your
children will as well
and also
these are the people if we so if we
accept my argument that actually
declining population is nowhere near
enough of an intervention to actually
delay the climate crisis or or prevent
the climate crisis
I think the only way out at this point
we're almost seven billion people on the
planet almost 8 billion rather is
technology
it's better means of of of energy
creation yeah it's the only way that
isn't there isn't another way there's
have you ever had this distinction
between light greens bright greens and
dark greens among environmentalists so
the light greens are the people who just
think you should like I'm I'm straw
Manning a bit but just think you should
turn the tap off while you brush your
teeth and just sort of like whistle
around the edges in terms of slightly
reducing your consumption and that's
sort of fine so they're they're the
least radical of everyone the dark
greens of the extinction Rebellion types
who say capitalism needs to be
overthrown a whole way of life is
disastrous you know who want to
completely upend everything and then the
bright greens are the people who say
what we need is technology and
Innovation to get us out of this so Elon
Musk is a bright green right so more
people means more chance of innovation
yes particularly the type of you know if
you if you're if you're the type of
Highly Educated person who really cares
about the environment and is going
around saying I'm not going to have kids
because of the planet you are exactly
the sort of person who's likely to have
children who are going to develop you
know
the next the next form of energy
that we need you know so I I
think that's probably the worst thing
you can do actually is to refuse to
procreate
and I and I also honestly think that
actually most people who say that they
don't want to have children because the
climate
they don't that's not actually the
reason
what do you think that's not the whole
reason well because
there tends to be a kind of bundle of
things
which feed into
all of the things which decrease
fertility you know things like being
um
being a religious
being a graduate living in a city
being left-wing those things also all
tend to go along with being very
interested in environmentalism
so there's a kind of cluster effect
where the it might be
uh sort of political expedient to
explain your reluctance to start family
as a result of of number five the
environmentalism but it's quite likely
that actually all all five are feeding
into each other
um even if it's not quite as
um
not quite as appealing an explanation
for other people or for yourself what do
you think for women
on a on an individual one you know each
individual woman the consequences of
them not having a child I'll give the
example of uh recently American comedian
Chelsea Handler doing these videos of
her living her best life on on uh just
Instagram and showing herself sort of
skiing and freeing and living this
luxury Jet Set lifestyle
and seemingly or claiming to be very
happy so that there is and and she has a
lot of support for that certainly from
Progressive circles
do you think that that uh that that
suggests that actually it's great not to
be a mother do you think that's correct
or what are the flaws in that line of
thinking
I mean I think it's really good fun to
be Child free when you're in your 30s
and I don't think it's very good fun to
be Child free when you're in your 80s
so so people are not wrong to recognize
that going on holiday when you have
small children is a nightmare I can
personally attest I have an almost two
year old we're basically just given up
traveling with him because it's a it's a
complete nightmare but it's like it's
fine just don't do that for it's not
very long it's not a very long period
for your life when you can't go on
holiday because you have small children
um but it is just it is
straightforwardly true that they are
expensive and
um
my friend Alex says that the um the only
thing that will limit your freedom more
than having a newborn is going to prison
which is true it's just true right but
also you you front load a lot of
exhaustion and expense
with enormous payoff
you know at the time babies are joyful
but also further down the track
there's an enormous payoff on an
individual level so
and so the the flip side of that if
you're if you're without child later
what's what are the downsides for women
specifically like what how do they and
you know it's I get I get the joke if
you're atheist and you have no children
it's sad but can you explain that to
people who maybe don't understand that
um
it is very common
for women in particular and men to to
regret not having children later it is
very common there are exceptions to that
but I think in general it is probably a
good policy when
mapping at your life to basically behave
as other people behave because the
chances of you being
an outlier are quite low most people
most people will not derive great
meaning in their lives from their
careers
most people will derive great meaning
from their children that's just true
there are exceptions but that's just
true for most people and it is fun
to have the freedom that comes with not
having children when you're younger
but when you're older and you are more
likely to be lonely when you're
dependent on other people for support
you know you can't depend if when you're
in your 80s you can't depend on other 80
year old friends
to look to look after you in the way
that adult children can and also you
probably aren't going to be able to
depend on the state either because
that's the other story in relation to
falling fertility
the welfare state is a Ponzi scheme
it always was right like when when the
odd age of pension was introduced when
the NHS was introduced we had a much
younger population on average we had we
had much higher birth rates
and no one ever expected
these things to become
I think six and six percent and seven
percent respectively of GDP which they
are now no one ever expected that but
it's already clear that
State pensions and the NHS and the whole
the whole welfare state
is not sustainable that's only going to
get worse with the child uh decrease
it's only going to get worse yeah so I
think the chances of me I'm now 31 the
chances of me getting to claim my state
pension when I'm 68 which I suppose you
will be able to do are non-existent
pretty much I think it would be gone by
then
you you touched on one of the first
slides of feminism and that answer is
that a career sorry yeah well I think
this is you can challenge me if you
disagree but the career is more
meaningful than having children and
something I've noticed in my generation
is is for women it's they've been told
to pursue a career to go
to University to go and seek work and
and
um
but you claim or you're arguing that no
that's actually not
it's not good for women
I think that's probably true for men too
I think the vast majority of people have
jobs not careers and that's actually as
it should be
it's it's it's it's it's it's
weird intellectual types like me yeah
you know who Define themselves by their
careers it's um that's not typical and I
don't think it ever should be
um most people derive most meaning from
their families and their friends in
their local communities and you know
there's so much data supporting this
this view that the things that make
people actually happy
are basically meaningful connections
with other people not abstract things
like
intellectual success or Career Success
um
yes but that that has been
a very dominant view in feminism for
some time that women ought to be
prioritizing
the life of the mind or the
um
success according to traditionally
masculine criteria
ought to be the goal
um
I think that partly comes from the fact
that sort of inevitably the women who
have the greatest power in setting the
cultural agenda and the political agenda
are women who have chosen that route and
for whom that route may be a better fit
for them you know there are there really
are outliers in a resurrection there
will be some women who have absolutely
no interest in having children
to whom it probably wouldn't be good to
have children because it's not you know
they wouldn't make good Mothers they're
not they're not orientated in that
direction and that's okay
um and who
are very driven in their careers and are
just temperamentally kind of more
masculine right those women are so much
more likely to be at the top of the tree
when it comes to
um powerful institutions like female
politicians for instance are so much
more likely than than the average woman
to not have children enormously so
inevitably those women are going to be
just a bit less interested
in
the alternative route
and in promoting
the interests and the viewpoints of
women who've chosen to stay at home I
mean stay at home mothers are probably
the least represented demographic in the
whole of the country in political terms
right because by definition they're not
in the corridors of power do you think
it's that within feminist different
feminist movements as well though
there's been a tendency to try and
strive for women to live equal lives to
men rather than embracing the great
things about
Womanhood because it's not necessarily
just the women who are in top in certain
careers who are as you say outspoken and
vocal have have the opportunity to speak
but the whole various feminist movements
it seems to be trying to level the
playing fields in a way that is against
female nature I mean in in your your
book you I think you you write feminism
needs to ReDiscover
the mother I'm not entirely convinced to
ever embrace the mother
do you think that's do you think that's
fair
um yes I mean so they have a feminism
historically very complicated political
movement and there are lots of different
warring factions
um
there have been strains of so-called
maternal feminism or difference feminism
or whatever which I'm to some extent
drawing on but in terms of the the most
dominant feminist ideas yeah yeah
there's a there's a
there's an antipathy to Motherhood and
that I think is kind of built in to the
ideology because
um
liberalism is really hard to to
reconcile with motherhood
and so to the extent that feminism is
derived from liberalism as the sort of
grounds of political movement
if if your priorities the freedom of the
individual
and if your unit of analysis is the
how on Earth do you deal with motherhood
because babies aren't really individuals
right because they can't
they can't survive proven an hour
without the devoted care of at least one
adult and mothers aren't really
certainly mothers when they have
newborns aren't really individuals
either I've heard from so many women
who've had newborns that going out of
the house for the first time
without your baby feels like missing a
limb that's the phrase I've heard so
many times and that's how I felt as well
and it eases over time you have this
kind of gradual process of feeling more
um separate from your baby
but certainly in the early days
mother and baby are a unit
and if you and if your understanding of
society is as is of
individuals sort of like atoms just
occasionally bumping into one another
but basically operating solo would you
do about the mother baby diode it just
doesn't really make sense and so your
options are basically
to
to be antenatalist to just say well it's
better for women if they don't have
children and some feminists are very
explicit in saying that
um not realizing I guess or not thinking
about the fact that that's a Surefire
way to to for your your movement to
commit suicide right if you're if the
people drawn to your movement end up not
reproducing then you rely on converting
other people's children to the ideology
but that's quite hard you know you will
you will eventually run out of other
people's children to convert
so is that the other option that's been
chosen by some feminists is to
um rely as much as possible on the
states
and to say that we should be
um
we should be trying to
disrupt that intense link between mother
and baby
and using State services to that end so
Universal daycare from birth
sort of thing
um and
uh rather than having women supported by
spouses having women supported by the
state that's the kind of socialist
feminist route
um as a way of dealing with this problem
of Freedom how do we maximize women's
freedom
um which do you support neither what's
your solution
I think it has to be the family
I think it's I think it's a picture
poison situation I do because I do
recognize that there are downsides to
um having women be reliant on the family
Network for support during the
vulnerable periods of pregnancy and and
baby Hood
but I also think that there isn't a
better alternative
because I don't think that the state
makes a better
replacement family I don't I think it's
worth saying that I don't think that the
nuclear family should be the only source
of support
I think that historically the norm for
humans has been to be embedded within
extended family networks and to have say
lots of
female kin
flock around that it used to be a
practice in the UK
um I did um
I I did a degree in women's history and
my dissertation topic was on um the
history of obstetrics in this country
and
um I don't know that word what is it
obstetrics childbearing oh sorry okay
yeah and there used to be
um
all sorts of practices we've completely
forgotten about which are completely
standard
like for instance the lying in period if
you ever heard a lying period no
where women would basically spend I
can't remember exactly the period it's
something like 30 or 40 days they after
birth they would spend being looked
after by other people in their homes
basically so this is obviously
pre-hospitals and
um and then you at the end of that
period you were churched you go to your
local Parish church and there is a
there's a um a service and then you're
sort of released from your lying period
And this is occasionally being
interpreted by some feminist as this
sort of almost like putting women in
perder like a women are sort of shut
away because they're dirty or whatever
that's not the purpose of a lying in
Period the purpose of the lying in
period is to protect you and the baby
from infection
because you're not going out and about
and risking disease and also to allow
you to recover from this you know
horrible experience of of completely
unanisitized child path
um and what's really interesting about
um that practice is is pretty much all
cultures have something like that and
it's all for about the same period of
time as well if you look at the um
whatever they call it lying in Period of
different cultures it's all like 30 40
days ish and the way that it's done is
that you have your female kin or
sometimes your female friends or
servants if you can afford them will
come and look after you during that
period and we'll do everything for you
that seems to be among most
cultures
the solution that is arrived at in terms
of how do you support mother and baby
doing that really vulnerable period
particularly of course in periods of
high infant mortality
um
and we don't do that I was kicked out of
hospital after less than 24 hours after
having a cesarean and in hospital I
basically no
support from anyone and in fact I mean I
to be fair I had babies during lockdown
but I wasn't I wasn't allowed even to
have my any of my relatives with me
in hospital like we've completely done
away with that and I think no wonder
women get such bad postnatal depression
because we've basically
we've just done away with the with the
village
that exists for precisely this purpose
so this is from the Industrial
Revolution basis yeah yeah and that's
where the big change so the the fix for
that is cultural then it's not really
political what can the state really do
to encourage that change in uh in in
looking after mothers
there there are some things that the
state probably can do I don't think that
um
what the state currently encourages
is for people to be as mobile as
possible
in terms of internal and also
international migration in order to
maximize
GDP
and also for
um
the state doesn't really recognize the
extended family it's just blind to it in
general how could it recognize it
one example I like to give is I have a
friend who had a baby when she was in
medical school
single mom and she somehow managed to
finish her degree miraculously and then
she was getting to the stage of applying
for her placements as a junior doctor
and she really really wanted to be
located near where her mum lives because
she wanted to
live with her mum and rely on her mum
for Chaka particularly overnight because
overnight Nursery closed what are you
supposed to do if you're doing a night
shift as a doctor and the NHS
bureaucracy just couldn't compute this
idea they were like okay so if you have
if you have a child in primary school
they respect that as a sort of
geographic limitation and if you have a
spouse they'll they'll recognize that
but they did this idea of like a
grandmother or what it's just sort of
there's no drop down menu option for
that because
that's just doesn't sort of figure
in policy making in general
um
I think it should
I think that we should be thinking about
trying to strengthen the extended family
in all policy making
um
and currently it's off the radar so
yeah it's not as if the state can just
wave a magic wand and return us to
um
the medieval village arrangement
but I think at the moment it does things
that further undermine the family
when it didn't like like that but how
else
so one example it sounds niche
the fastest growing type of households
in this country is the
multi-generational households are three
generations living in the same
house so for economic reasons because of
the housing crisis or yeah so it's
partly to do is it's partly to do with
young people not being able to afford to
buy their own property so they're
staying at home for longer it's also
partly to do with older people just
living
for such such a long time that it can be
the best option for a family to have you
know to have a granny flat or whatever
and to have an elderly person move in
um it's also quite a good arrangement
when it comes to child care potentially
if you've got
um an older relative living with you who
can help sort of around the edges in
terms of
um child care then that's can be quite a
good arrangement for people
um part of the reason that it's growing
as a household type in this country is
because of South Asian communities are
much more likely to adopt
that practice and not not necessarily
because poverty it's not like there's no
direct correlation between choosing that
option and being poor is actually
because it's culturally considered
normal to have your elderly parents live
with you rather than have them in
institutions
um there are all sorts of really dumb
barriers to multi-generational
households right things like just
getting planning permission to build a
granny Annex or whatever or it's
difficult to get a mortgage because
there aren't bespoke mortgage products
available at most High Street Banks
when you've got you know so you've got
one generation you have a lot of equity
but basically no capacity to raise a
mortgage and then you've got another
generation who might not have as much
Equity but can pay off the mortgage over
a longer period like that's just the
sort of thing that High Street Banks
struggle with they needn't there's
nothing inherently Difficult about that
it just needs
um potentially some some quite small
policy tweaks
um but until now I don't think
government's really been used to
thinking
in those terms about how to actually
knit families together
rather than just encourage people to
maximize their their earnings at all
times one of the brilliant features in
your book which which I think is one of
the contentious issues of today in
feminism is
is the idea and I think you use the term
uh equal above the head so
um
have you have you had I imagine you've
had pushback from that particular point
because that seems to be something that
people disagree with and um but it seems
obvious to me that that biologically we
are different and that hormones would
have had different effects have
different effects on men as they do to
women and and
um what do you think why do you think
that's such a contentious
uh issue and why is that so problematic
for feminists
the word that I've some that I've heard
quite a few times is that I'm being
defeatist
in thinking that there are ways in which
men and women on average psychologically
different different from one another and
that those differences aren't going to
go away
um
that is seen as kind of giving up
just accepting crucially accepting male
violence you know just saying that well
men in every time and place that we know
of have always been more
aggressive and physically aggressive
than women
um so it's actually not really about
women it's about it's sort of an apology
of that men behave badly if you accept
that it's not really to do with yes I
think it's also seen to be feeding into
I mean you know there are historically
instances of
um
scientific sexism shall we say you know
what is it like
um there was I can't remember the exact
number now but
um women's Brains on average are smaller
than men's Brains because women are on
average smaller than men and
um there was some Victorian scientists
who got very preoccupied with the idea
of I think it's the missing five ounces
so yeah so trying to explain women's
kind of cognitive inferiority on the
basis of just brain size
um I mean we now know that actually
average male and female IQ is the same
yeah exactly
um so that was that was dodgy science
yeah but that clearly they clearly have
been examples of of
scientific sexism being put to that end
and so some feminists here
me going around saying that men and
women have
important psychological differences and
they that's that's the fear that that's
where that heads
um towards just legitimizing the
mistreatment of women how do we overcome
that fear
I think the problem is that it's true
what's true that there are differences
between men and women psychologically
it's just true and it sort of doesn't
matter whether or not you think that
that truth might be misused by Bad
actors it is just true and I think that
I don't think we solve anything by
trying to pretend otherwise
and I think also that when you
withdraw from a discipline like say
evolutionary psychology which most
feminists are very suspicious of
what you end up doing is having no
ability to contribute to that discipline
you know if anyone with a kind of
feminist inclination rushes out of
discipline you sort of Leave It to the
you leave it to the Bad actors right
you're likely to actually produce more
dodgy anti-feminist science because
you've just you've just you've given up
I mean that's defeatist arguably right
yeah I think we should say
the science is morally neutral
if it's true it's true what we decide to
do with that truth is up to us we can
put it to whatever political ends we
want to and and I think that actually
there are ways in which you can use say
evolutionary psychology
to ends that
um promote the interest of women which
is what I'm trying to do so what would
be an example of that so on the
sexuality issue for instance which I
write about at length
um
there's copious evidence to suggest that
male and female sexuality on average is
nearly different and men are for
instance more likely to be interested in
casual sex than women social sexuality
sociosexuality yeah so that's your your
innate tendency should always be
interested in sexual variety men are
hiring that trade than women there's
lots of overlap you know it's something
that um often really clever people are
bad at understanding is the idea of
overlapping bell curves and the idea
that you can be you can have at the
population level you can have a
difference but there can still be
individuals for whom to whom that
doesn't apply
really smart people can completely lose
their senses when confronted by this but
that's that's what we're talking about
in when it comes to sociosexuality and
indeed much else
um
I don't think it says women's interests
to
pretend as I think we have done for half
century now that the only reason that
women don't like casual sex as much as
men is because they've been repressed
and that if only women could be freed
from that repression that's the other
great lie of feminism it seems yeah and
that they could have sex like men and
that this is what women really truly
want underneath all of the sort of
pedrock or nonsense
um I don't think that's true an
evolutionary psychology would support
that view it should be very obvious
intuitively why the sex who who risk
much more
from any section encounter in terms of
pregnancy in particular why they would
be the picky SX and why they would be
less Keen to jump into bed with someone
they don't know
um
and if if you if you can accept that
premise then
the
distress that is widely reported by
young women in particular as a
consequence of hookup culture
can be understood not as
the sort of vestiges of patriarchal
sexual repression still playing out
when women are shamed you can see
it instead as a completely
good and natural response from women who
are actually being put under pressure to
have sex they don't really want to have
and I think actually if we're really
interested in protecting those women's
well-being I think continuing to try and
make them behave more like men
is not going to do that and actually you
argue for the
for marriage as the as a trying to be
very controversi yeah yes so the
feminist case for marriage yeah which is
which I've written for the for the
spectator as well
um which is that if you're going to have
children particularly
the
the data suggests
and history suggests that the only
stable institution that has proven
itself to actually protect the interests
of women and children is
marriage monogamous marriage
and basically all cultures basically
your culture is either opt for
monogamous marriage or
polygamous marriage so one man multiple
wives one fact from your book that I
found really surprising was that
historically only 15 of of cultures have
um monogamous uh relationship as the
norm have mandated monogamous so what
quite a lot of cultures do is they
permit polygamy which is not to say that
every marriage is polygamous but they
permit it
um Christian cultures for instance don't
and that is the unusual that's the
unusual one okay sorry but I interrupted
you so uh well and polygamy is bad news
for women in general
um there are loads of
domestic violence is higher in
polygamous cultures for instance
um child abuse is is more common
um there's higher crime rates
because you've got all these
um unmarried angry men who are more
likely to commit opportunistic crimes
um monogamous marriage has a whole bunch
of downsides
but at the societal level
we haven't yet found a better structure
and various experiments
you know by
um utopians having sort of
I mean one of the things that Jermaine
Greer for instance imagined in the
female eunuch
um published in
the 70s I think 1970 was um
having women living in sort of communes
with one another and then men might
visit occasionally you know all of these
kind of experimental setups
um they've never lasted
people have tried them at various points
in history not just post sexual
Revolution
and um
they don't seem to work they don't
actually seem to accommodate human
nature in the way that you need them to
well so as well as what I think we have
a mother motherhood crisis we also have
a marriage crisis and I think it's
something like the now the the average
age for a woman to be married for the
first time is in I think it's 32 and for
a man it's 34. and in your book you go
into uh detail about that really from
the 1969 divorce act and how drastically
things have changed since then I think
you you go into if I remember correctly
and correct me where I'm wrong it's uh
back 1968 eight percent of children were
born out of wedlock and now it's 50 of
children are born out of wedlock
so that's about right sounds about right
yeah so
marriage is completely as an institution
been worn away and and how how can we
change that culture if indeed
uh polygamy is worse for us as you've
argued how do we change it and make and
make marriage cool again
[Music]
um
well in general the way you make things
cool again is when high status people
adopt them
it's true for basically everything
so I guess if you wanted to make
marriage cool again
you'd have rich men and hot women
adopting it
simple as that okay I mean that's just
true those are the those are the
quickest route to status among human
beings
um I don't know how we do that of
Designing designing that particular
policy I I guess I will leave okay so
then how do you how do you win that
argument with the with let's say in
feminist circles or how
in in the in this in the discourse how
do we persuade marriage as the the
worth redeeming
well I mean one of the things that's
worth noting is that
um
the which you are the more likely you
are to get married and stay married
really yeah and so the poorer why so if
you're poor you're less likely to yeah
why is that
I don't know they're different there are
different views on it the if you come
across Rob Henderson's idea of luxury of
beliefs no so Rob Henderson is um
uh psychologist writer very interesting
very interesting person and he um is
best known probably for his idea of
luxury beliefs so this is he defines it
as
um a belief that confers status on the
upper classes
while the costs are born by the lower
classes
and he Compares it to a um
a sort of an ideological Revlon good so
verblin good is um a good that is more
desirable because it is expensive so
like a Rolls-Royce
identifying the normal laws of supply
and demand a Rolls-Royce is desirable
because it's expensive because everyone
knows it's expensive you can only access
it if you're very rich right
um Rob thinks that this also applies to
political ideas
so if you can hold to an idea that is
actually very very
costly
for you know not for you but for someone
less privileged than you it actually is
a way of
boosting your own status and advertising
your own your own status so an example
he gives for instance is
um
uh
uh drugs if you go around saying that
you want drugs to be completely
legalized you don't understand all the
stigma about drugs whatever
um if you live in a nice expensive part
of town and you can afford to go to very
expensive rehab
that doesn't
cost you anything but it does cost
someone who lives in a very poor part of
town and is likely to have you know the
house broken into by junkies and to have
needles in the child's playground and
whatever it costs them a great deal so
it's a luxury belief in the sense that
it is a way of
boasting about your own
status
without suffering any costs and I think
marriage may be an example of
what sorry opposition to marriage maybe
an example of that oh it's just thinking
of Chelsea Handler is a perfect example
of that but mostly my privilege without
showing any of the costs yeah because
the people disproportionately who suffer
from family disintegration are poor
people particularly poor women and
children
um
yeah I think it was um
I can't remember who said this not me
I'm stealing from someone but I can't
credit them because I've gone he said um
the real leaders from the sexual
Revolution weren't men weren't women
they were children
um
I think that's true there's so much
evidence to suggest that divorce is a
complete disaster for children yeah on
mass
um like it's worse for your parents to
get divorced and for one of your parents
to die
in terms of the impact on
yeah yeah wow
um uh so uh then what does the uh
future look for feminism what do you how
are you now Mary Harrington's just put
out her book feminism against progress
and she cites you at length which I
imagine is very flattering
is there a sort of comeback uh for
traditional or conservative feminism
so the term Mary has coined is um not
conservative feminism but reactionary
feminism which is partly a joke
um because it's funny and because you
know you're preempting what people are
going to say about you
um sort of reclaiming the word
reactionary which is funny
um but it's also
it I think it does also describe quite a
serious political idea the problem with
describing this program as conservative
feminism is it suggests a slightly
different relationship with the recent
past it suggests that what you're trying
to do is cling on to
the status quo whereas actually as you
know in relation to marriage for
instance
um what is Edge cling on to he's already
dead
you know the idea that we're going to
sort of just stand to thought history
yelling stop and that's enough
you know that what we're actually
thinking about here is a is almost a
reconstruction process
and I think
I mean
reactionary feminism is is basically
just a funny meme that became a a
serious political idea but I think I
think I think part of what we're
actually feminism describes and what I
see as being part of what I'm trying to
do
is recognizing that there are lots of
ways in which our current
cultural moment is very very strange
there are all sorts of things that we do
which are very odd and are largely
result of our material circumstances the
fact that technological processes
progress has been so rapid people
haven't really kept pace with it in
terms of our social institutions
and this kind of liquefying effect the
technological progress has on
communities and traditions whatever
what what I think the reactionary
feminist
says to this is okay we don't say well
let's recreate the 1950s then you know
let's let's look to the fairly recent
past and say she almost goes back to the
medieval right yeah yeah yeah so really
exactly super trade yeah so Mary so Mary
for instance would argue and did argue
in a great ass issue years ago from
which famous against progress is partly
derived
um Trad wives aren't tried enough yeah
because actually yes it's she very
Condes that actually women
um were probably better off in
pre-industrial Revolution on some
metrics on some metrics yeah no not at
all but definitely this idea of progress
being a straight line it's nonsense
um
I think what the reaction with feminist
project is is to look across time and
place
you know ambitiously not just look back
to 1950s and say okay what are the
common themes here what are the what are
the Norms institutions ideas whatever
that seem to best promote human
flourishing what do all cultures end up
settling on we just spoke about the
lying in period you know if everyone's
doing this except us
is that because we are uniquely
enlightened or is that because actually
we're the ones who've gone astray should
we be should we be returning to the
lying in Period should we be trying to
actually sort of reconstruct from
from the past ways of structuring human
life which actually
promote women's interests promote
everyone's interests better than what we
do right now
that's I think what reactionary feminism
is people seem to be quite into it I I
uh do you take issue with any of uh
Mary's thoughts on it where do you think
you divide from are you split from her
um
I joke but it is also true that I'm
Mary's gateway drug you know she's a
she's a more she's a more radical
thinker than I am in certain ways but
then I think that's so valuable
because she she follows some of these
ideas through to their most over some
window pushing conclusions
like no sexual marriage so Mary for
instance has a whole chapter where she
argues against the pill which I didn't
quite do in my book I I
present some of the arguments against
the well I I present some of the ways in
which the pill has caused some social
destruction and I
push for some degree of kind of
restraints but Mary goes the whole way
so you're still quite in favor of the of
of that of contraception in that in that
sense it's not she you think there's
there's Stills plus sides but whereas
Mary's kind of get married first and
you know it's basically strict
Christianity it seems like
yeah Orthodox Christianity without the
Christianity without Christ yeah sort of
reconstructed from first principles yeah
um yeah I mean I don't
I use contraception
within marriage but like I don't
I actually I don't want to go to the
pill it's really useful
it's basically my view while
simultaneously recognizing that there
have been destruction pretty much the
whole chapter yeah massive consequences
of the pill yeah so some people would
say I'm a hypocrite maybe they're right
great well on that note
Louise Perry thank you so much for
speaking me today thank you
foreign
[Music]